j'ai d é simulation est une entreprise
située à l encours développement de
logiciels fabrication de systèmes
électroniques ou encore assemblage de
produits tout cela pour fabriquer des
simulateurs destinés à l'entraînement
des forces armées
c'est l'activité de la soixantaine de
salariés sur site et pour en parler nous
sommes avec le directeur général de ge
et des dissimulations francis d'orvault
bonjour bonjour vous existez depuis 70
ans donc comment a évolué votre activité
alors je n'étais pas là au début de
l'activité en dérive années 1950 la
société a commencé par faire des
activités liées aux valeurs tournant de
l'activité initié le nom initial de gier
avions d'oran dont fait différentes
activités dans la chimie dans la signer
dans l'électronique les activités autres
que l'électronique ont été vendus avant
les années
le mille la société a été reprise en
1996 par le groupe aérospatial dans le
cadre des activités missile qui
nécessitent des simulateurs avec des
traitements de données un peu
confidentiel et la troisième étape pour
résumer la vie de l'entreprise
c'est que mba a racheté la propriété de
la société en 2000 le fin pour
constituer un grand pôle européen de
simulation au service des forces alors
je le disais un cd simulateur qui sont
destinés à l'entraînement des forces
armées
concrètement comment ça se passe nous
sommes le premier partenaire de l'armée
de terre française pour la préparation
opérationnelle des forces avant les
hôtes ex
ce sont des simulateurs qui sont
déployés sur le terrain qu'ils font qui
nous permettent de faire de la guerre
électronique au service des forces en
fonction de la doctrine en simulant en
temps réel en environnement réel les
manoeuvres de combat nous sommes le
dernier stade d'entraînement avant le
départ en opex décès quelle est la
stratégie de votre entreprise du coup la
stratégie de notre entreprise c'est
d'abord d'être au service des forces
pour la préparation opérationnelle comme
je le voulais indiqué c'est d'être un
acteur global sur la simulation
puisqu'aujourd'hui simulons dans notre
domaine d'excellence à peu près
l'ensemble des armes de le terrain c'est
à dire que sa part du fantassin ça passe
par les blindés notamment du programme
scorpion et ça va aussi évidemment vers
les missiles la troisième dimension dans
le cadre du rapprochement que nous avons
avec un bébé ça c'est le premier
deuxième volet l'opérateur global est le
troisième volet c'est de s'appuyer sur
un grand groupe industriel qui avaient
des acquis et numéro un en europe à
vocation internationale qui nous
apportera autant que de besoin
ir les soutien technologique dont nous
avons besoin voire le soutien financier
nous efforçons de plus en plus de faire
croître la valeur ajoutée c'est-à-dire
de faire des activités de développement
de nouveaux produits faisant appel
nouvelle techno mais des produits qu'ils
soient génériques et qui après peuvent
se déployer dans différentes versions
donc ça il ya une augmentation sensible
de la valeur ajoutée donc merci francis
d'orvault merci et on va rejoindre tout
de suite valentin real pour découvrir
justement quelques simulateur et savoir
notamment comment ils sont fabriqués
[Musique]
nous sommes avec le responsable business
development valentin real bonjour
bonjour nicolas
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire qu'est
ce qu'on voit autour de nous alors ici
on présente des simulateurs stc et ace
au t on à la dst rx et mmp qui sont
utilisés en salle donc le mp basé sur la
3d les rixes sur la réalité augmentée et
on a plusieurs versions du stc b2m qui
donc lui fonctionne en laser donc on a
un bep deuxième sur mitrailleuse 12,7 et
un b 2e sur sniper doucette ces
différents armes qui sont utilisés par
l'armée française c'est exactement ces
différentes armes qui sont sains de
l'infanterie française devant nous un
système des simulateurs de tir missiles
antichars et même pc ça exactement elle
se tait donc ainsi un simulateurs
d'entraînement au tir donc un système
qui est utilisé en intérieur qui aide le
tireur à s'approprier le système à
apprendre à faire des tirs et à
maintenir ses compétences dans le temps
comment ça fonctionne concrètement alors
comment ça fonctionne
on a ce faux postes de tir qu'à une
reproduction du vrai poste de tir la
même paix dans lequel on a intégré
toutes les ja chem toutes les interfaces
qui sont en contact avec le tireur donc
on a la vraie bonne êtes les vrais
systèmes livrés il est vrai les vrais
boutleux rebbouh tonique relié à un pc
qui vivent à gérer un environnement 3d
envoyé dans l'oeuf au poste de tir et
qui permet aux tireurs d'avoir
l'impression d'utiliser un vrai système
dans un vrai un terrain 3d fait un petit
essai on va faire un petit aussi
[Musique]
on vient de l'essayer concrètement
combien de personnes travaillent autour
de ce système
et puis quel métier on retrouve alors on
a eu une bonne dizaine de personnes dans
l'équipe de développement de ce système
plus environ 5 à 10 personnes dans
l'équipe d'industrie lisation et de
soutien on a du développement logiciel
mais on a surtout des développements
mécanique pour reproduire le système
d'armes intégrer les vrais partis du
système d'armes à l'intérieur
on a dû développement électronique pour
toutes les cartes d'interface et de
gestion de la boue tonique
on a de l'optronique pour tout ce qui
est intégration du micro moniteurs et
donc de celle en tire ensuite on a des
personnes qui gèrent ce qu'on appelle
ici le dossier donc la conformité du
système
on a des chefs de projet à
l'industrialisation en bas on a des
personnes des techniciens qui vont en
fait monter le système dans une salle
grise et ensuite sur le terrain on ad on
a des anciens militaires quittent avec
nous pour maintenir le système faire en
sorte qu'il soit toujours disponible
pour les forces vous occupez de toute la
filière
vous concevez le produit vous
l'industrialiser et puis vous assurer le
service après-vente exactement ensuite
toute la vie du système pour faire
bénéficier les forces d'une
expérience maximum autour du système
être sûrs que le système soit toujours
prêt et fonctionne nominalement vous
recherchez des compétences aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on cherche surtout des
personnes capables de développer du
logiciel ca de l'hôte du logiciel
embarqué ou 3d et des personnes au
niveau de l'électronique numérique
merci valentin regeal de rien
responsable business development chez
j'ai d é simulation et le ska ico se
poursuit